I was watching Blackbird Yeah by myself
and I love dark [__] I love you know
look at me yeah geez Louise and I was
just enamored I was so
look I'm not blowing smoke I I tell
everybody and their mother they've got a
seat if nothing else for your
performance because it's just like you
can't take your eyes and I remember the
first time you open your mouth as uh
Hall Larry Larry Hall the serial killer
right yeah yes
um because something said like in Wiki
it's a suspected serial killer I guess
in the story he's just suspected yeah
and then they figure it out but I
watched his performance and you do
it's so it's so unlike you I mean it's
the it's like
well I know you're not a serial killer
but no I'm no I know your mannerisms
your voice I've never heard this so
maybe I have but sell them from an actor
I don't know what you did but you would
be talking to eagerton right yeah and
you'd be having a scene with him and you
go your voice would go up and it would
sort of go down so you go well yesterday
when you were telling me that you had I
was like what is he doing and I couldn't
stop listening to you you know what I'm
talking about it's the voice and the and
the draws you in a little bit and it was
kind of sad and you didn't want to like
him but you kind of weirdly were
starting to and until things started to
unravel I was I was just blown away I
thanks thank you man I think uh yeah man
Taryn Edgerton I I always say I'm like
he's a really good dance partner like
sometimes you just get
blessed with a co-star who you're doing
the majority of your the bulkier work
with and it's like hell yeah uh he's one
of those hell yeah guys
um but I I yeah I try to get Uber
specific and just try to make it honest
and
um and
not you know crazy my brother when I did
the movie I Tonya my brother Matt
um he he was with me on a leg of the
press tour for that or at least he went
to the love doctor New York Premiere
great oh great dope movie just a cool
unexpected yeah like I was like all
right let's go see this and I was like
right it was really well you know the
first time I read that script uh I was I
was in Canada doing a pilot for a
lifetime with a bunch of bunch of cool
people and you know the show was just
okay not something you'd be like I gotta
tell you about the show Emma but the
people were like fun and we're having a
great time up there and I'm feeling so
blessed and spoiled to have this type of
a gig series regular they're paying me
decent even though I've got like nine
lines in the pilot right it's so easy
but but I'm there and I get the offer
for the audition on I Tonya
um because I think Josh Gad had the role
but then he got busy with brano's uh
Train movie The Murder on the order
Express uh murder on the Asian Express
yeah you can't say that
Kenneth Brown a [__] [__] what are
you thinking man
um but I'm like prepping for the
audition I'm reading the script and I'm
laughing my ass off the first time I
read it it feels almost like a
Christopher Guest yeah or something yes
and I'm like a psychotic Christopher
Guest fan
um and then Michael McKeon on oh stop
yeah stop he was on Smallville too he
was great
we've been emailing back if he's like
yes I'm coming I figure it out but go
ahead
um but I a second time I read it I
wasn't laughing it read more like a
David or Russell thing where I'm like
these are broken people who are bleeding
all over the place type of thing and and
I was like well that's kind of a good
sign if one made me laugh and the other
almost made me cry just on separate
reads and I'm like this is a cool movie
but then when you're doing it you never
you never know you know you never know
wait why was I talking about because you
were getting to blackbird
Blackbird uh because you're uh oh crazy
people do another crazy so my brother
said to me on that leg of the tour
whatever he was like
you know crazy people my character in
Italian Sean Eckhart he's like crazy
people don't know they're crazy and
that's what's so scary about crazy
people because we're all capable of
doing something crazy and what most of
us have but
this idea that you don't know you're
crazy like that's crazy that's scary so
with Larry Hall I just had to really own
that crazy and not be not let the
audience think that I'm cognizant of it
and yet he's emotionally manipulative
for sure and that is what the audience
clues in on a little bit and they're
like okay well I was almost starting to
like this weirdo so long as I don't have
to stand next to him and then uh and
then it's like okay now now I think you
might be messed up oh he's oh he's that
messed up oh I hate this guy kill this
guy yeah and then of course we the
audience feel what Taryn feels an
episode but it was an arc it was just uh
you had to get there it wasn't just and
I always say this it's like you know if
you're gonna play the bad guy yeah
you gotta because bad guys normally
aren't trying to be hated they're you
know they're trying to get what they
want yeah they're trying to you know
they're manipulative they're psychotic
they're uh narcissists or whatever it is
um but yeah that that was incredible I
always think that the best villains in
stories or at least talking movies TV
are the ones who spell out what it is
they're trying to do
they'll actually
give you a verbal peek behind the
curtain as to what what's making this
what the engine of thought is so like
Heath Ledger when he's burning the money
and he's like it's in dark now he's like
it's not about the money and like
uh Christoph Waltz in the opening of and
glorious bastards where he's like let me
let me explain how I see the Jews or
whatever like knowing the Mind behind it
is so
it's such an intimate thing for an
audience to clue in on and it makes you
hate the person even more and it's and I
feel like we did that in in episode four
or five we start to really flirt with
knowing why Larry did what he did and
then it's like oh to this extent oh did
somebody kill this guy yeah yeah
absolutely all the great villains you
get a peak I think yeah it's almost like
they're like this but this is what I
believe Christopher Waltz what does he
hasn't he sound I don't know I've never
done for Chris Wallace I don't know but
I know he does this thing where he talks
about Quentin Tarantino that's it that's
it off the cup